j'accueille maintenant un autre marin un
autre grand marin voici michel rocard
[Musique]
mosher locaux 3
michel rocard bonsoir bonsoir
donc vous voyez vous êtes à côté vous
êtes entre bandes a commencé par une
causerie fut un tout petit vin mais non
arrêtez vous c'est vrai que c'est pas
grand gel avait un mauvais mari adore ça
vous êtes l'inventeur de la deuxième
gauche c'est quoi la deuxième gauche oh
non je suis pour l'inventeur de la
deuxième gauche
l'inventaire va deuxième coup c'est un
nommé jean jaurès ouais jeu séculaire ce
truc la deuxième est fière je tempère
avant principaux il y en a un qui est
jacobin centralisateur uniformisateur
commandant très politique ne croyons pas
beaucoup syndicats ni aux accords et
pensant que tout se décide par la loi
par le règlement par la discipline et
c'est jules guesde
paul fort tout le monde a oublié mais
c'était le chef entre les deux guerres
c'est le chef donne et englos et
guy mollet françois mitterrand thérapie
dans cette gauche ainsi fabriqué dans
notre pays bizarre c'est toujours les
minoritaires se compose le pouvoir qui
ont été le mieux entendu de l'opinion
aux différentes époques et c'est jean
jaurès léon blum pierre mendès-france
aujourd'hui peut-être jacques dollars et
moi voilà c'est ça voilà les roues des
66 vous imaginez la décentralisation
avec un ouvrage s'appelle décoloniser la
province c'est un motif 1 quand même
très bien surtout qu'ils ont la ferme
est recyclé gentil je leur reconnais je
vois les gens regardent george et moi
j'adore rythme à trouver le sommeil
jeudi deux passes il ya toujours l'effet
frères gardien le rude on va donc faire
aucun lien donc vous êtes l'homme du
règlement du conflit en nouvelle
calédonie l'homme du rmi de la csg
aujourd'hui vous militez pour le
désarmement nucléaire notamment
bon alors ça c'est tout ce qui est
positif dans ce cas négatifs
c'est vrai enfin négatif ce n'est pas de
votre faute mais vous avez été le
souffre douleur de françois mitterrand
rien de négatif ce n'est pas ça vous ont
empêché le président la république quand
même j'en ai assez fait pour m'arrêter
avant bon c'est bien ça
alors vous êtes vous savez que vous
allez me faire un plaisir formidable
ouais ça fait 20 ans que le truc effet
j'ai 70 ans j'en ai plein la gueule
c'est la première fois que j'entends à
la pas seulement à la télé dans la vie
en général quelqu'un place et la csg
dans les trucs positifs
vous venez de le faire prodigieux à
mauriac toussaint matin et défoncé
s'agit aussi
parce que c'est en effet un bon truc
soit 15 % des français y ont gagné de
l'argent mais ils le savent pas mais
votre destin attendait quand même vers
la présidence me dites pas c'est pas
grave j'en avais fait assez on peut dire
ça bon je suis planté ou neuf dixièmes
de la route à aider quand même
il est probablement plus important de
laisser des idées qui font souche que de
signer des trucs soi même est ancien
contrepèterie bien alors michel rocard
ou publie un livre un livre d'entretiens
avec gide 23 chez flammarion donc à
parler maintenant de faire jamais
président là il a bien vu aux riches
elle l'a dit on l'a fait donc si vous
voulez vous imaginez balladur en train
de faire ça pour coupat pourquoi pas
bien dont j'allais sur lui sa liberté
ses chances mais tout à fait que je suis
démocrate
bah oui je vous avoue j'ai un syndicat
des mecs qui ont failli être présent
dans le public je pense vous avez entre
vous alors collection en mémoire vivante
donc entretien comme je le dis avec jean
xxiii
c'est votre parcours d'homme politique
vous êtes né en 1930 effectivement comme
vous dites ça vous fait quand même au
moins 70 ans vous avez 10 ans voit un
bon poids vous avez dix ans quand la
france est envahie et vous fait vos
études sous l'occupation
votre père grand résistant quitte la
france ont en 43 et pendant un an et
demi vous n'avez pas d'autres nouvelles
de lui que les messages codés qu'il vous
envoie par l'intermédiaire de radio
londres
alors votre père c'est un grand
physicien non dangereux c'est un des
pères de la bombe nucléaire et voilà
alors c'est terrible votre père a été un
des inventeurs de la bombe nucléaire
française et vous vous êtes contre la
prolifération des armes atomiques
oui il ya des contradictions dans toutes
les familles moi ma mère est bon mais je
me laisse pas donc c'est
logique s'agit alors votre première
prise de conscience politique c'est en
45 vous êtes scouts par d'occupation
s'est interdit d'être scooter pendant
l'occupation
oui on s'appelait patronage mouvement
n'était pas scout est alors à la
libération et éclaireurs unionistes et
vous allez accueillir les déportés qui
reviennent des camps et ça effectivement
ça vous marque profondément que vous
avez 15 ans vous voyez ça importe qui -
sur la marques et n'importe qui et la
deuxième prise de conscience et quand
vous découvrez un jour qu'hitler a été
élu au suffrage universel et vous vous
dites la politique ça peut être
dangereux vaut mieux s'en occuper
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
commente vous résumer tout lé non
j'avoue il a fait la politique mais vous
l'avez faite bien alors j'avance moi je
fais le pitch au lycée vous découvrez
que votre talent aux mathématiques sont
pas à la hauteur de la tradition
familiale veut dire nulles ah ouais
j'avais jamais osé mon père est mort
maintenant fait assez saurait le dire
poliment je leur ai posé dans votre
famille sont tous normalien aux
polytechniciens dans tous pour les
techniciens de père fils mon père ayant
trahi mais vers le haut normal c'est
encore plus assez mieux enfin c'est ce
qu'ils croyaient vous connaissez le mot
de clemenceau en 1919 ouais merci
ils voulaient empêcher l'allemagne de se
relever
crazy une école polytechnique oui
d'accord mais quand même d'une cruauté
rares alors un jour donc vous voyez bien
que vous avez pas y arriver quoi et
profitant d'un voyage de votre père aux
us and mr à rome vous inscrivez à
sciences po
votre père réagit très mal allez vous
coupe les vivres t'imagines la famille
quand même me dis je vais faire sciences
po lieu de faire polytechnique où le
couple est alors vous devenez tourneur
fraiseur dans un labo de l'école normale
supérieure et la gagne un peu de podium
et pourquoi je raconte ça parce que je
suis votre conscience l'éveil de votre
conscience politique que j'essaye
d'expliquer là vous êtes initié au vécu
de la classe ouvrière par un
contremaître trotskiste ancien des
brigades internationales en espagne
tourneur voilà un gars qui avec la tuque
delvigne un tour avec de manivelle était
capable de vous tailler une demi-sphère
trop loin ça va intéresser macgyver
ouais ça va lui interactions et la face
aux comme ça mais en même temps à me
raconter la guerre d'espagne c'est vrai
oui alors c'est vrai quand on vous
soupçonne d'être un socialiste de droite
quand même quand on voit d'où vous venez
c'est pas si c'est pas si simple que ça
quoi là ça va être compliqué aulas il ya
deux définitions de ce que c'est que
d'être de gauche y en a une par le
s'avère le pognon veut plus de podiums
et c'est pas un autre il ya des tas de
gens qui bouffe mal l'ennui c'est que
trois ans après l'inflation vous l'a
rappelé le plus souvent et look manière
c'est les droits le droit d'exister le
droit de se syndiquer le droit de parler
le droit d'être entendu le droit des
trois présentés le dos l'équivalence du
droit des femmes par rapport à celui des
hommes
le pacs la reconnaissance tout ça sont
des droits et cette définition de la
gauche élus cré des droits qui sont
irréversibles eux et c'est l'anti
colonialisme maintenant moi je me suis
battu pour le droit du peuple algérien
j'avais balancé sur l'algérie à un
moment définition d' à gauche au nom de
laquelle je suis entré c'est celle des
droits - la bataille pour la dignité
faut aussi corriger les inégalités mais
c'est plus fragiles parce que c'est à
remettre sur le chantier tout le temps
ouais voilà comment je suis en train de
le coup j'ai parlé politique pardon ça
va c'était clair c'était clairement mais
on n'est pas contre la politique michel
dans des contrées chez eux en fait ils
ces catégories année j'essaye de ne pas
appartenir maintenant dans le petit con
alors après la guerre bat vous parler un
petit peu de vos amours mes premières
amours alors cessé mes premières amours
furent protestante dans le cadre pas
d'accord les premières annonces sur
protestante dans le dans le cas de la
paroisse
mais après mes premières amours les plus
profondes or il ya des premières amours
les premiers seulement les plus profonds
en 3d fait gaffe en disant ça mais
furent cependant anglaise donc on a
compris que dans la paroisse il se
passait pas grand chose
c'était quoi baiser avec la langue et
puis après l'angleterre c'était un peu
plus sérieuses et sa niche elle qu'elle
pas
michel mais avant britanniques furent
fabuleuse et platonique
ah bon ouais les britanniques ce furent
la télé convenablement elle était
fiancée en plus mais c'est quand même à
ça que je dois te parler anglais ce qui
est dans le monde contemporain skate par
rapport à $ oui bien alors votre
première femme était d'ailleurs
cheftaine chez les louveteaux way de
route à sa demande doit décoller non je
rigole pas du tout la deuxième vous
l'avez rencontrée au ps eut ouais vous
avez emménagé avec elle en mai 68 et en
91 vous annonciez avec sincérité rare
dans votre milieu
enfin chez les hommes politiques en tous
les cas votre séparation ouais
s'appelait michel rocard c'est ça ce qui
vous embête et vous avez tous les deux
michel rocard donc elle s'appelait
messieurs le wave and trop le dire comme
ça
dites-moi deux couples deux échecs c'est
pourquoi votre mère était trop possessif
c'est ça non d'autres biens j'ai en
effet mais très possessif qui va pas
faciliter mes rapports avec la partie
féminine de l'humanité qui est pourtant
la plus délicieuse pour piger peut-être
pas eu de chance et puis j'ai peut-être
pas fait ce qu'il fallait
peut-être que je suis un mauvais mec une
interview qui vous alors vous entré en
politique à travers les réunions
d'étudiants de socialistes je ne faisais
pas la carte d'ailleurs et vous
rencontrer jacques chirac était
socialiste à l'époque jacques chirac il
n'aurait plus n'ont jamais réussi à lui
faire signer la demande d'adhésion mais
il venait souvent réunion je
m'organisais nous étions de la même
promo de sciences po m'étais bien
copains c'est vrai qu'il a défendue
l'appel de g oui justement je vais tout
vous dire il me considérait comme
beaucoup trop réactionnaire pour lui
chirac chirac ce livre vous
l'interrogiez vous le confirmera remet
en doute pas une seconde de votre parole
mais il était plus à gauche que vous
chirac
oui c'est pour ça que ces fonds ont fait
rien tant avouez quand même c'est génial
on découvre aujourd'hui que mitterrand
était de droite que chirac était de
gauche alors qu'ils sont fait élire sur
un programme contraire ça en dit long
sur la politique en donner 15 secondes
là un bout de mon père et il apprend que
je deviens socialiste catastrophe non
seulement tu vas bharati n'était pas bon
pour les sciences exactes mais en plus
tu veux faire la politique à gauche là
où ils sont ou seront site était comme
tout le monde c'est mon père qui parle
tu serais trotsky
ouais tu voudrais tout casser ça ne te
ferait que deux ou trois ans parce que
tu comprendrais si tu deviendrais normal
mais si tu commences social-démocrate tu
va le rester
oui et ça c'est pire rassam a été dit
j'avais 19 ans et je suis toujours là
alors vous avez été vaccinées en fait
contre le contre le communisme parce que
quand vous avez lu le livre de
kravtchenko c'était en quelle année ce
bouquin après la guerre c'est tout 48
qu'est ce qu'il y avait dedans
la description de l'omnipotence
policière et du contrôle d'un régime sur
les relations personnelles les
déclarations la vie privée les paroles
de tout individu dans toute une société
totalement insupportable et décrit avec
un tel talent littéraire que vous ne
pouvez pas douter que c'est un
authentique ça ne peut pas s'inventer
mais c'est un livre qui a été connue à
l'époque
harbaugh je pense bien ça me fait un
immense chahut et comment vous expliquez
que des gens sensés après l'avoir lui
soient restés au pc soit resté stalinien
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont besoin
d'une église et dans toute église des
combats à la fois au moins n'importe
quoi le communisme était une église les
croyantes sont restés croyants du moins
ils sont tirés petit à petit petit à
petit ça a pris du temps quand même
parce qu'avant il y en a qu'une autorité
oui je sais bien ça fait beaucoup plus
tard ça fait quarante ans plus tard mais
le livre nous nous parlons a été un
événement formulation est en fait le
premier est celui ci n'est venu trente
ans après avec beaucoup plus de force
ouais mais 30 alors vous êtes pour
l'europe et vos amis de l'époque vous
disent pas finalement écouté pour
l'europe est situé socialiste vient avec
sefyu slaï sefyu à l'époque c'est un
parti c'est parti de guy mollet le parti
de la guerre d'indochine le parti de la
guerre d'algérie le parti des scandales
du vin des malgré tout vous y allez oui
parce que j'aime pas les petits trucs et
l'impuissance
ouais et qu en plus j'avais dix nord
l'idée qu'on pouvait chante contribuer à
changer les choses
d'autant que
l'invitation est allé me venaient de
copains qui pensaient comme moi il
fallait aller bousculer ce truc et que
c'était la tâche que les jeunes auraient
à faire alors après l'excellent
guillaume changer les moeurs noël métier
qu'est ce qu'il a dit alors été fabuleux
à qui vous avez envie de donner du sens
aux collègues dans la navigation ouais
bon bien sûr mais j'avais envie de
donner des leçons aux collègues en
politique a fait pareil et après les
faits le même score alors après après
vous fondez leroy pas faire toute
l'histoire enfin vous retrouver la tête
du ps su qui était je sais pas ce qu'ils
font c'est compliquer la génération
précédente mais je deviens le patron
huit ans pour la centrale n'est pas trop
déçu qui le parti organisé qui est au
coeur des événements de 68
vous êtes un des principaux
organisateurs des défilés de 68 et à
cause de vous vous en féliciter et
jamais eu de débordement ya jamais eu de
l'assemblée nationale n'a jamais été
attaqué la bourse n'a jamais été attaqué
les bâtiments publics en jamais été
attaqué donc vous êtes celui qui a fait
jouer vous et moi tout seul est celui
qui a fait échouer 68 finalement pas
pour être méchant mais là vous venez de
dire une connerie
ah bon jamais personne mais 68 n'a eu
cette idée mais il y avait des
provocateurs dans tous les compartiments
et est donc premièrement tous nos
services de nounous service d'ordre les
gars qui vérifiaient un peu que les
choses se passent bien et est toujours
en queue de manif pour empêcher les
énergies sle casseurs les voyous y en
avait d'aller casser des vitrines et des
est de changer l'image de ce mouvement
qui voulait parler au peuple en se
faisant voir mais pas plus mais c'est
vrai que je n'ai jamais eu une
difficulté à obtenir de cohn-bendit de
sauvageons d'alger smaerd tous les
les dirigeants de mai 68 dont j'étais le
plus gros de marquera enfin tous ces
gens là jamais j'ai eu des difficultés à
obtenir que dieu ait pas d'acte de
violence
mai 68 est un acte de témoignages et pas
de violence en plus c'était plutôt
ludique
c'était une demande du droit à la parole
c'était un combat contre les hiérarchies
qui permet pas qu'on cause en dessous
dans quelques disciplines que ce soit il
ya eu à la fin de 68 le stade charléty
où tout le monde était réuni c'était le
point d'orgue des événements vous parlez
pas vous à charléty des mendès france
qui est avec vous ne parle pas non pour
moi ma ds a refusé oui pourquoi il
sentait pas la chose il avait passé son
temps à nous dire le gaullisme était
dans la rue il mourra dans la rue nous
lui avions dit on lui avait dit vous
nous fatiguez le gaullisme il est réélu
d'étape en étape ya des référendum la
constitution est légitime il ya des
élections chez électorale et puis ça
continuera et nous sommes en réplique
présidentiel ou parlementaire
et puis pendant mai 68 vous avez raison
bon c'est vous qui avez raison le
gaullisme est dans la rue peut-être y
mourir mais alors à vous de jouer
elie non je sens pas le mouvement c'est
un peu excessif c'est un peu excessif
n'a pas voulu parler du coup il ya eu
d'énormes plus de paroles mais tout
syndicale
ce jour là le mouvement était enterré
les gaules et je crois qu'ils l'ont
tairai le lanceur surlendemain en fait
ça a été enterré dans les pièces en cash
enfin il a été enterré le dimanche soir
de la veille quand la défense a défini
par la porte et du coup aucun politique
n'a parlé donc pas moi voilà alors 69
êtes candidat à la présidentielle vous
êtes seul leader politique d'ailleurs
d'aujourd'hui enfin avoir commencé par
la présidentielle ouais je suis même le
sol des marginaux en être échappé oui
oui à 3166 pour ça c'est ça
fo se raser je regardais la glace en se
rasant le lendemain matin à 10 heures
tout ça était quand même pour une cause
sérieuse très fort 66% mais c'était
annonciateurs et là vous rentrez dans
une opposition à françois mitterrand qui
prend son se sont non non non non on
positionne en france habitants est une
chose bien plus ancienne que ça des
accords centralité tu sur ce qu'il a
fait pendant la guerre d'algérie
oui c'est pour ça qu'ils allaient assaf
505 vous l'avez pas laisser rentrer au
ps ça qui était le nom c'est pas moi
j'étais militant de base à l'époque en
cette décision il a toujours cru que
c'était vous qui aviez refusé de le
faire un cv sous alimentées un peu mais
il savait tout mitterrand le bureau
exécutif du ps hudon jeu du ps a donc je
n'étais pas parce que j'étais un
militant de base avait décidé que on
voulait pas de lui qu'il ne voulait pas
de lui moi j'ai eu c'est vrai presse
en 81 vous voulez être candidat à la
présidence de la république
ouais mais il ya un gros vent c'est
l'appel de conflans 1
il ya un gros morceau en face vous
faites un peu un flop faut bien le dire
dans la vie politique et dans les médias
et là vous décidez vous rallier à
mitterrand pour le choix aux convois
d'investiture j'aurais perdu tout le
monde peut se planter en échange de quoi
vous êtes vous êtes ministre un échange
pas ouais enfin bon je suis vous
démissionner quand mitterrand en
instaurant la proportionnelle pas ce que
vous dites c'est un boulevard pour jean
marie le pen
ouais je te vois mais cela arrange et
mitterrand de faire un boulevard le pen
ça lui permettrait de couper la droite
ont deux oui mais ça en gpo l'idée que
je me fais le job a tordu comme ça enfin
vous êtes attendus à ce point là vous
l'idée de laisser monter deux bennes
pour casser la droite vous l'auriez pas
ce fait rien faire des tordus ou pas
tord des cellules une affaire de savoir
si on croit des choses et si on pense
que la dignité ou l'honneur sont des
valeurs avec lesquelles on a quelques
relations c'est peut-être dignité et
redonner à présenter à un public
finalement le méchant vous il doit être
possible pensez support - clémence ou un
brillant il ya des gens honorables qui
charles de gaulle tout de même il est
pas nécessaire de se déshonorer pour
être président de la république bien en
88 vous êtes premier ministre alors pas
très marrant parce que quand vous dites
là mitterrand est ce que c'est bien de
prendre dumas dans le gouvernement aux
affaires étrangères vous pensez que
c'est pas une bonne idée que c'est parti
très fréquentables dumas il vous dit
bien sûr pourquoi c'est dans la
constitution c'est lui qui nomme pour
moi je propose lui aussi la tête elle va
encore un point commun méritait pas ça
un témoin moi je verrais part alors en
novembre 98 a déclaré michel rocard
mon vrai problème c'était que françois
mitterrand n'était pas un honnête homme
et tout est dit lui il en avait autant à
votre service dans le livre de favier
martin roland en parlant de vous il dit
j'ai fait l'erreur de le nommer en
parlant de votre nomination à matignon
il dit j'ai fait l'erreur de le nommer
alors on est quitte à matignon il ne
faisait rien c'est gentil très sympa il
était incapable de prendre une mesure un
tant soit peu impopulaire est alors par
rapport aux européennes ce que vous avez
reproché à mitterrand nous a remis tapis
dans les pattes pour les européennes ce
qui était pas faux lui il disait il dit
que j'ai envoyé un missile tapis cet
idiot une pichenette aurait pu la battre
en parlant de vous tous c'est d'une
amabilité c'est sympa la politique ça je
savais pas mais je savais que vous aviez
dit que ce n'est pas un honnête homme ça
je savais mais attention sur ce mot j'en
attendais je sais si vous allez me dire
venir le honnête homme au sens du xviiie
mais oui mais comme on dit un homme à
être sinon one malhonnête
ouais je pense nous le dire au sens que
la grande langue française et le 18ème
siècle ont donné au mossad et hommes il
ne remplissait pas toutes les conditions
ça que j'ai voulu dire plus il avait la
culture de l'homme est homme mais le
comportement d'un homme parlait bien
alors je pose une question très sérieuse
la françois mitterrand à votre avis
est-ce que c'est un socialiste ou un
vichyste déguisé en socialiste pour
prendre le pouvoir
c'est une question trop brutalement
formulé comme c'est mon genre
oui c'est votre genre mais c'est pour le
bien de chacun sans jardin de square
être se répondre c'est un homme qui
avait dans le fonctionnement de la
république et les lois laïques de la
république une vraie foi qui considérait
que de gaulle débat fouet qui a
rencontré la gauche par hasard
d'alliance dans ce combat et qui l'a
mené jusqu'au bout avec ses méthodes à
lui qui ne sont pas toujours les miennes
ouais en parlant d' avouer là nous
penser que chirac il devrait aller voir
le juge halphen vous on s'est compliqué
ça
pas tellement il est convoqué par un
juge je suis passé juriste ni assez
informés des trucs pour savoir si le
vieux gm n'a pas ou un petit peu
outrepassé ses fonctions faucheux à coup
sûr c'est quand même quel que soit
l'homme un peu important que le
président de la république d'un grand
pays continuent à être respecté et par
conséquent vous faire attention à ce
qu'on fait faut être sûr de soi un
témoin c'est un témoin c'est pas un
accusé
mais mais tout de même il est gravissime
d'y aller sans certitude je ne peux pas
répondre mais parce que je n'en sais pas
en plus constitutionnellement quand même
il n'est pas faux que le président de la
république ne soit pas en état de
répondre oui oui enfin c'est des actes
qui ont été commis avant qu'il soit
présent dans le public
alors c'est la rakija tout une
interprétation juridique sur laquelle le
juge halphen aurait mieux fait de se
rendre compte qu'il y avait matière à un
débat qu'il aurait dû faire trancher par
ces experts ou sa hiérarchie avant de
prendre le risque de faire bafouer louis
hon
quelle que soit la vente encore une fois
la présidence de la république france
est un grand pays on a un peu de
noblesse on espère on mérite le respect
de nos voisins ou du coup on espère on
joue pas ça trop facilement clinton
aussi les diriger un grand pays
le problème des bonnes institutions
c'est qu'elle tienne le coup même quand
les hommes sont faibles les choses c'est
pas de la tarte
s'il prend facile d'affaires bien
maintenant
michel rocard e vous avez jamais été
président si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil une seule chose met mon mandat en
balance sur un mauvais résultat
l'élection européenne
ouais pour me faire jeter sur hazard par
mauvaise foi et raté par la
l'investiture
si ma faute technique quand vous avez
perdu européenne vous n'auriez pas dû
partir finalement vous dois dû rester
oui à mesure j'ai rêvé et un an et demi
avant reprocher à laurent fabius ne
l'avoir pas fait ce que tous les grands
dirigeants européens font une élection
perdue on s'en va ouais je fais partie
de cette race est aussi ma dignité
je suis partie sur une faute tactique
mais au moins dans la dignité relève
marc mercier
le pire est à venir michel rocard ah ah
le pire est à venir c'est l'interview à
leurs torts aux embauches par an dans le
ring pour le bush par amandine gamme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne n'a bougé c'est parfait dès
qu'il ya un premier ministre plus
personne ne bouge j'adore l'interview
l'arthrose comme son nom l'indiqué
michel rocard quel est pour vous le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour fait plus mal
le lieu où c'est impossible et où c'est
impossible je ne sais pas en tout cas je
j'ajouterais volontiers la coucher d'un
beau bateau à c'est agréable dans la
couchette dans mon bateau suprême avec
le ca verse s'avère vite et il est tout
seul avec les dorades est-ce que vous
avez besoin de faire l'amour pour aimer
ou des mets pour faire l'amour besoin je
sais pas mais ça va pas mal ensemble
comme ouais ouais un peu besoin quand
même comme tout le monde
ouais pour ce poète anormales sur ce
sujet est ce que vous préférez une femme
qui baissent bien mais qui est infidèle
ou une femme qui baisent mal mais qui
est fidèle jamais eu à me poser la
question
et vous tiberghien avec la fidèle ou une
femme qui fais mal mais les fidèles
en fait il n'ya tu préfères vous allez
au bout d'un an ça ça dépend si c'est
pour une nuit même si c'est pour la vie
michel rocard est ce que vous préférez
une femme qui couche avec un autre en
pensant à vous ou une femme qui couche
avec vous en pensant un autre vous
mettez dans un reee hier que j'ai peur
rencontre et ça a dit djilla été mariée
deux fois oui crois que
que je suis plutôt d'espérer qu'elle
pense à moi bien même si elle couche
avec un autre ça vous préférez alors ça
vous amuse mais vos impôts m voilà ça
vous amuse toi préféré qu'elle qu'elle
pense à vous dans le couple est ce que
vous pensez qu'il vaut mieux tout se
dire ou rien savoir
c'est le dosage de l'antre 2 qui ferait
bon koup à vous préférez aller à cette
coupe
ouais bah oui c'est pour ça que je vous
fais cette interview que vous êtes
impression spécialistes est ce que vous
préférez
aulas est ce que préfère être caressé
par quelqu'un qui vous dégoûte ou battu
par quelqu'un qui vous aime a battu par
quelqu'un qui m'aime attention vous
seriez un peu non non c'est grave on se
renseigne ici vous savez comment c'est
est-ce que vous préféreriez que votre
femme vous quitte pour un homme pour une
autre femme à partir en elle même qui
est libre à l affût de manquera c'est ça
la gauche
peut-être il ya peut-être le pacs est ce
que embrasser s'est trompé non ah bon
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
philosophie que vous nous travailler
lâche ses pages ou demande maljean mais
ça dépend du contexte et j'espère bien
que non ouais ouais et sucer c'est
tromper et pardon sucer c'est tromper
non plus non plus après
il
le corse et flamands
j'ai voulu être
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus